[Música]
yo les quiero contar parte de lo que es
mi vida
y yo soy un enfermo un enfermo renal y
por lo general cuando uno dice enfermo
entiende que es una persona que es
solamente carente de salud y no es tan
así
cuando uno está enfermo no solamente
carece de salud sino carece de un montón
de cosas que en las que no está firme
por ejemplo no está firme en la economía
no está firme en el trabajo no está
firme en la pareja
no está firme en los vínculos y no está
firme en los amigos que por cierto a mí
me ha pasado
y además no tiene salud es algo bien
distinto
yo en el año 2007 en el año 2007 me
descubrieron una enfermedad que se llama
poliquistosis renal
y eso me me me hizo ingresar en un mundo
absolutamente desconocido para mí que es
la hemodiálisis
más o menos todos me imagino que saben
lo que se trata de que se tratara de
hemodiálisis ese es un tratamiento
sustitutivo del riñón estuve tres años y
medio en hemodiálisis y la verdad es que
no la pasé del todo bien hay una frase
de flaubert que dice la manera más
profunda de sentir es sufrir por ello y
pese a que ahí me ven con una cara de
felicidad porque no la pasé tan mal en
hemodiálisis
y me surgieron muchísimos problemas
más que nada emocionales en mi centro de
hemodiálisis y realmente me emociono y
perdónenme por esto en mi centro de
hemodiálisis éramos 9
de 19 de mis ocho compañeros yo que soy
el último el último que está vivo
perdí mi trabajo me echaron porque en
definitiva era un enfermo
y me quedé absolutamente desprotegido
frente a la nada
entre una espada y la pared sin saber
qué hacer
no sabíamos cómo íbamos a comer el otro
día en realidad esto que les digo
teníamos embargada a la casa no sabíamos
cómo íbamos a encargar el próximo día y
además teníamos teníamos cuatro hijos
era un panorama absolutamente desolador
absolutamente triste
y entonces
en esos momentos donde uno está en
hemodiálisis que son cuatro horas por
vez tres veces a la semana 12 horas de
su semana están ocupadas en en
hemodiálisis en un centro
yo perdí más de 1.820 horas
[Música]
laborales por dedicarle a la
hemodiálisis que me sirvieron para
estudiar estudié filosofía estudie algo
de aerodinámica medí me dediqué a mí
mismo y la verdad es que salí
beneficiado de ese tratamiento porque
siempre lo vi como una segunda
oportunidad nunca lo vi como la
posibilidad esté latente de mi muerte de
mi muerte próxima siempre le vi como una
posibilidad de dar un paso un paso más
en realidad hay tres cosas que fueron
las que me ayudaron a poder salir de la
diálisis y sobrellevar la o sobrellevar
la diálisis en realidad primero pensé
que
era muy ignorante en los tratamientos
que estaba teniendo entonces necesitaba
información la pasión
que pese a que muchos hablan de lo
apasionado que es uno o siento pasión
por determinada cosa de la pasión les
vengo a informar lamentablemente que la
pasión es sufrimiento
la pasión viene de patio que sufrir
no me queden a mí piensan en la película
de la pasión de cristo es absoluto
sufrimiento o si no cuando dicen siento
compasión por alguien es acompañarlo en
el sufrimiento al otro
lo otro que también entendí es que tenía
miedo y la única manera de vencer ese
miedo era con coraje coraje obviamente
también soy muy fanático de la
etimología de las palabras coraje viene
del de curas de poner el corazón por
delante en francés
yo siempre digo que el corazón siente
antes que el cerebro y es real esto yo
si yo se los preguntar a ustedes
muchos me dirán el cerebro pero no el
corazón siente un nanosegundo antes que
el cerebro eso es una mil millonésima
vez de un segundo
por algo existen las corazonadas quien
ha sentido corazonadas todos
todos cuantos de ustedes han sentido
celebradas
ninguno cuando se finaliza un vínculo y
dice me rompiste el corazón
rompiste la cabeza porque me diste con
un fierro pero no me rompe el corazón de
corazones porque se trata de amor
y las otras tres cosas que me parecieron
absolutamente importantes no son mías
pero son de la cinta leve que es un
matemático y un ensayista libanés que
habla sobre la fragilidad la robustez y
la anti fragilidad
yo siempre digo que lo frágil son los
juegos de té que compra mi esposa
alejandra que tenemos más o menos 60 o
70 y somos dos en una casa
el ejemplo que les quiero dar de la
robustez es la banca por
la banca es absolutamente robusta pero
tiene algo de fragilidad ante el menor
cambio la banca quiebra estamos viviendo
hoy en nuestros países lo estamos viendo
tanto en argentina como en uruguay ante
el peor el menor movimiento la banca se
viene abajo yo era muy rápidamente
y la otra versión es lo anti frágil
lo anti frágil es lo que se mueve dentro
de luego de un desastre se hace más
fuerte es aún más fuerte que la
resiliencia cuando a mí me dicen son muy
resilientes yo digo no yo fui anti
frágil porque de un desastre un desastre
literal pude convertir algo que hoy está
ayudando a un montón a un montón de
personas en el mundo para ser más
exactos 156 mil personas en el mundo
[Aplausos]
los emprendimientos tecnológicos las
soluciones innovadas e innovadoras
también son anti frágiles ya mí eso me
parece absolutamente fascinante que un
emprendimiento tecnológico que de
repente empieza a funcionar como el caso
nuestro desde la cocina de nuestra casa
sean anti frágil y haya empezado con
apenas 14 centros
12 de uruguay 1 de argentina y uno de
brasil hoy tenga más de 8000 centros en
todo el mundo me parece absolutamente
fascinante por todo lo que hemos logrado
esta es nuestra nuestra plataforma hoy
nuestra plataforma que lo que hace es
coordinar diálisis para que distintos
pacientes del mundo que son 7 millones
puedan viajar y continuar con su misma
calidad de vida como antes de tener la
patología
hoy se cambió el paradigma la gente no
dice más necesito un centro de diálisis
en san pablo- un centro de diálisis en
río de janeiro o un centro de diálisis
en buenos aires que eran los lugares más
cercanos les hablo siempre desde uruguay
pero seguramente desde desde argentino
de rosario pasado a lo mismo
cambió el paradigma hoy la gente dice
quiero un diálisis las quiero en aruba
y ya dan por descontado que se las vamos
a conseguir entonces acá si compran
primero el pasaje luego el hotel y la
diálisis me la mandan a mí como diciendo
bueno soluciona me la diálisis campeón
tenés 15 días para solucionarla y yo
digo te les tengo que explicar que la
realidad cuando vos pedís un turno con
un oftalmólogo se demora dos meses como
yo puedo conseguir diálisis en 15 días
cuando es un tratamiento de alta
complejidad es que le estamos generando
una crisis de expectativa muy muy alta
pero eso es culpa nuestra por nuestro
trabajo porque sabemos hacerlo muy bien
hoy nosotros tenemos 113 personas
trabajando más un equipo legal etcétera
zetas son somos 133 personas trabajando
para pacientes y lo más lindo de todo
esto
yo entendí
como una epifanía
en un momento yo podía seguir informando
a las personas sobre qué iba a pasar en
determinados tratamientos en el mundo
dije si yo lo puedo hacer porque no lo
puedo hacer otro al mismo tiempo ganar
dinero hay un montón de pacientes que se
han quedado sin trabajo o que trabajan
medio turno entonces salimos a buscar
pacientes en todo el mundo que pudieran
ven torear a otros pacientes que
quisieran viajar y ahí atravesamos
prácticamente todo el planisferio y
cumplimos un rol social muy muy
importante tenemos 88 mentores que son
pacientes en hemodiálisis y
trasplantados que ayudan a otros
pacientes a viajar y los motivan para
que sigan viajando y sigan llevando a
sus familias a continuar en vacaciones
porque eso estaba absolutamente
prohibido yo les digo que hoy tenemos 7
millones en el mundo de pacientes a los
que obviamente queremos llegar pero al
mismo tiempo una familia promedio son
son cuatro personas cuatro personas este
dentro de un grupo familiar estamos
tratando de trabajar para 28 29 millones
de personas es muchísimo
este y en ese trabajo estamos en franca
enfrascados y creemos profundamente que
lo vamos a hacer hoy nosotros tenemos
156 mil pacientes como les dije estamos
en 250 países más de 8000 centros y
tenemos 7 oficinas en distintas ciudades
del mundo
somos la primera plataforma a nivel
global y piensen que salimos de esa de
la de la cocina de mi casa de una mesa
cualquiera esté y la verdad es que a mí
ya todo nuestro grupo de trabajo nos
llena de orgullo y les juro que hoy me
emociono de contarles
[Aplausos]
hernán casciari todos ustedes lo conocen
hernán
mientras nosotros no teníamos ingresos
no tenemos casa de verdad no sabíamos
que si vamos a comer al otro día era
terrible
decidimos alquilar una pequeña parte de
nuestra casa por el bien de uno de ellos
de los huéspedes fue hernán casciari
para su mala suerte al segundo día de
estar en nuestra casa infarto
y esta alejandra que anda por ahí este
y lo tuvo que llevar a nuestro a nuestra
ambulancia
estas nuestras ambulancias
alejandra subió hernán que estaba mucho
más gordo lo subió rápidamente a la
ambulancia
alejandra mide un metro 80 y tiene una
voz de mando bastante importante y yo le
hago caso siempre
lo subió a ese a ese cucu este y empezó
a circular más o menos 60 a 65
kilómetros por hora porque nada más
en un momento encuentra un patrullero y
le dice usted
al policía hágame una cápsula el policía
lo miro convenciendo la mira como
diciendo señora usted está loca o no es
no se tiene que ser algo un cargo muy
importante
de hecho el policía le dice sí señora le
pone un patrullero adelante un
patrullero atrás y una moto y un
trayecto que hacen habitualmente en 40
minutos desde mi casa a los el primer
hospital que está más cercano
6 son 16 17 minutos si hubiésemos si
hubiese llegado ella en tres o cuatro
minutos después hernán subirse muerto
cuando hernán se recupera éste se quedó
a más o menos unos quince días
la operación fue fue muy rápida para
peor esté inconsciente desde el estado
desde la unidad de cuidados intensivos
éste
la plataforma orbyt le pidieron que
hiciera que leer un feedback a mí que me
diera un feedback como anfitrión y
obviamente la casa y este anormal
éste estando acostado intubado etcétera
etcétera a julieta le dice lo siguiente
excelente vivienda para huéspedes
sedentarios y con propensión a el
infarto de miocardio
la zona es preciosa y posee comunicación
directa con los mejores hospitales de
montevideo mentira totalmente los
anfitriones javier a alejandra se
conviertan al instante en ángeles de la
guarda y te salvan la vida sin conocerte
te lleva muy rápido al hospital en súper
poco 8 mientras estás muriendo y después
se quedan en la sala de espera hasta que
los médicos te ponen un bypass no
permiten que caigas en depresión y que
te sientas solo te traen libros para que
le hace además no te quieren cobrar los
días que te quedasen de más en su casa
muy recomendable
lo más loco de todo esto es que este
este feedback es leído por el director
para el bien vi en miami
muy loco
y se lo pasa a young hevia que es el
cofundador del bien vi en san francisco
la verdad que nosotros habíamos decidido
tomarnos unos días de vacaciones y nos
fuimos el 31 de diciembre para menos de
100 kilos no nos daba el dinero nos
fuimos a menos de 100 kilómetros de
montevideo el 31 de diciembre me llegó
un mail
de este personaje y
la compañía está valuada hoy en 60
millones de dólares su fortuna personal
está en 7 billones de dólares de falta
se puede dar algún lujo que otro
me mandó un mail y me dice que podía
viajar a montevideo
y yo siempre pregunto lo mismo si a
ustedes de un mail el 31 de diciembre de
mark zuckerberg y siendo los quiero
conocer
yo no mando spam
[Aplausos]
mi esposa como es absolutamente
diplomática le dice sí señor por favor
lo estaremos esperando con este con lo
que usted merece etcétera etcétera una
cosa como muy todas todas romanticona
estos gringos se toman las cosas muy a
pecho
le dijo ok consigo un pasaje y salgo
para ahí
31 de diciembre voló el primero de
diciembre lo tenía en mi casa
10 días pasó a mi casa
diez días andaba medias por mi casa
y estos graves no
en el medio ahí porque en un momento
veía que las manos se cruzaban se
tocaban ellas mi hija a la izquierda
se tocaban iban y venían estuvieron
saliendo etcétera etcétera no estar
haciendo mucha vuelta la realidad que
estuvieron saliendo y ahí se forjó el
vínculo que nos ayudó a hacer lo que
hicimos con él con perdón con conector
médica liar bien vi les quiero contar
una cosa para terminar una cosa que me
pasó como esta cadena de milagros
absolutamente maravillosa yo fui
trasplantado el 9 de julio del 2017
y yo tengo la misma enfermedad que tenía
mi padre que murió a los 48 años hoy yo
tengo 48 años
la misma enfermedad la tiene mi hija que
tiene 24 años la mitad de la edad que
tenemos los dos que teníamos los dos
y ese ese día a mí me sucedió una cosa
muy milagrosa
le dije en a 9 de agosto mi papá
falleció el 11 de agosto de 1988
salgo de la operación y mi médico que
eran obviamente en el prólogo pero al
mismo tiempo era bandoneonista me dicen
dos días javier te vengo a tocar el
bandoneón y yo estaba entre morfina la
hora que estaba muy perdido no me di
cuenta ahora que me estaba diciendo le
dije sí sí está bien
efectivamente el 11 de agosto
de 2017 a 29 años de la muerte de mi
padre él me deja el bandoneón allí en la
unidad de cuidados intensivos
a las seis de la tarde viene para
tocarme a todo esto yo les quería pero
mi padre de chicos me decía chiquilín de
bachín y yo nunca supe por qué me decía
chiquilín de bachín jamás ni me puse soy
muy inquieto pero jamás me puse a
investigar porque me decía el chiquilín
de bachín
entonces
a las 6 de la tarde llega pone su atril
shuttle y está y se pone
a preguntarme qué canciones okay tangos
yo prefiero dije yo quiero que me toques
adiós nonino y dijo que intentó cara de
una niña
toco adiós nonino y ahora me puse a
llorar
toco milongas argentinas y me tocó la
cumparsita
y en un momento se hizo un silencio y
empezó a buscar
otra otro tango y buscaba y buscaba y
buscaba
y en un momento me dice te voy a tocar
un tango que no es muy conocido música
de horacio ferrer que es uruguayo
y letra y perdón y música de astor
piazzolla y se llama chiquilín de bachín
yo realmente entendí ese mismo día
estaba alejandra a un costado escuchando
conmigo estaba yo obviamente en la cama
estaba gerardo y revoloteando como un
duende en esa habitación de la ciudad de
la unidad de cuidados intensivos estaba
mi padre
entonces es como un homenaje a mi padre
y perdonen que se me quiere la voz
a mis 8 compañeros que vi morir en
diálisis les quiero dejar hoy chiquilín
de bachín
[Aplausos]
[Música]